welcome Gamers to the future of portable
gaming today we're diving into the world
of Nintendo and the highly anticipated
next generation of the Beloved Nintendo
switch no I did not write that so I
started working on a video about the
Next Generation Nintendo switch we know
it's coming we just don't know when and
so I started thinking about some of the
best features that I would like to see
in a new Nintendo switch so I said let's
see what AI thinks I don't know if I can
read this with a straight face man hey
what's up fellow Gamers it's your buddy
here back again with some exciting
Nintendo switch news today we're diving
deep into the next generation of the
Nintendo switch and the incredible
features that'll make you jump out of
your seat with excitement buckle up my
friend because this is going to be one
heck of a ride oh my gosh dude all right
let's get into it my gaming pal it
actually wrote that imagine gaming on
the go with Graphics so sharp to leave
you breathless the Next Generation
Nintendo switch will bring you the power
you crave with a more powerful Hardware
capable of delivering stunning for 4K
visuals when connected to a compatible
TV get ready to experience your favorite
games like never before with vibrant
colors and incredible detail okay so a
little bit too heavy on the commercial
like advertising feel way over the top
obviously but not bad I mean there were
some roots of some actual good ideas in
there hopefully the next gen system is
more powerful hopefully it has a DOT
capable 4K say goodbye to dull and hello
to brilliant the Next Generation
Nintendo switch will feature an OLED
screen bringing you deep blacks vibrant
colors and enhanced contrast for an
immersive gaming experience whether
you're playing in handheld mode or
docking it to your TV every pixel will
come to life making your adventures
truly Unforgettable and OLED screen
would be great I hope that is in there
but that script oh man rough so
everything I was getting at this point
was just sounding so incredibly over the
top and no one would take it seriously
so I said make it sound less like a
commercial and more like you're talking
to a friend well right now it seems like
AI can't really distinguish very well
between a happy medium between the two
because
well just roll it now my friend
flexibility is the name of the game the
next gen Nintendo switch is all about
giving you the freedom to play your way
whether you feel like kicking back on
the couch or taking your gaming
Adventures on a wild road trip this
console has got your back switch between
docked and handheld modes effortlessly
and game wherever your heart desires
it's all about finding that perfect
gaming Groove perfect gaming Groove it's
not like a Just Dance reference again
some seeds of good ideas in there but
the way it is structured okay let's take
a moment to appreciate the fact that the
Next Generation I cannot keep saying
Next Generation Nintendo switch can we
please give a name generate name ideas
for the successor oh Nintendo Evo switch
no Nintendo switch X not bad but I feel
like X is already taken by Xbox no one
else can do it Nintendo shift that's not
terrible Nintendo Fusion
I kind of like Nintendo Fusion I feel
like it's just gonna be switched too
right it has to be switched to although
Nintendo has never used that naming
scheme yeah the original Nintendo Super
Nintendo Nintendo 64 the GameCube the
Wii the Wii U I guess would be the
closest they ever came and that was a
colossal failure so yeah maybe they will
pick something totally different okay
let's take a moment to appreciate the
fact that the Nintendo Fusion is going
to honor your beloved switch games yep
you heard it right backwards
compatibility is here my friend so all
those hours you poured into saving
princesses exploring Dungeons and
discovering Hidden Treasures won't go to
waste your entire gaming library is
ready to join you on this exciting New
Journey it's like a reunion with you
it says it's like it's like Iranian with
your gaming buddies I mean I I can't I
appreciate the sentiment but just just
imagining that being red like can we
just take a second to appreciate the joy
that joycon control oh I can't can we
that joycon controllers bring to our
lives that's a dad how do they know I'm
a dad well get ready for even more joy
because the Nintendo Fusion is upping
the game The Joy cons are getting a
serious upgrade with improved ergonomics
enhanced precision and a connection
that'll make you feel like you're in
total control get ready to lose yourself
in the game like never before though
hi oh my gosh you guys
all right composure composure I have to
deliver this line for you guys I have to
deliver this line those thumbs are going
to be dancing it's it really is in here
oh all right this one I think you guys
might like this one all right my friend
time to unleash the Nostalgia the
Nintendo Fusion is bringing back some
serious retro goodness with a true
Virtual Console okay dude that would
actually be awesome think about all
those legendary games from Nintendo's
Rich history links Adventures Mario
Shenanigans and so much more it's like
stepping into a time machine and
reliving the magic all over again get
ready for a blast from the past like
you've never seen before okay this one's
actually not bad there's a few things I
would change get ready for a blast from
the past eh don't know how I feel about
that Mario Shenanigans I think we'd have
to use something besides Shenanigans but
a true Virtual Console that'd be awesome
let's talk personalization my friend the
next gen Nintendo switch is all about
making the console truly yours customize
your gaming experience with a range of
vibrant themes that match your style and
personality and hey no more messy game
collections organize your games with
folders making it easier than ever to
find your favorites it's time to create
the ultimate gaming Sanctuary all right
again that was that was solid that was
solid obviously I hope folders and an
improved OS is something we see in the
next gen switch oh man the next one oh
we got another doozy here say goodbye to
those heart-wrenching moments when you
have to delete games to make room for
new ones the Nintendo Fusion is stepping
up at storage game my friend with more
internal storage you'll have all the
space you need for your growing library
of Adventures download to your heart's
content and immerse yourself in a world
of gaming goodness it's like having a
bottomless pit of fun a boss bit of fun
not what I would have went with there we
all know that gaming is better when
shared with friends right is it always
though well get ready to take your
sharing game to the next level with the
Nintendo Fusion capture and share your
most epic gaming moments effortlessly
show off your insane victories hilarious
fails and jaw-dropping achievements to
the world because gaming is all about
celebrating those Unforgettable moments
together okay it brought it back it
brought it back there toward the end I
do hope that the new Nintendo switch has
vastly improved share features I'd love
to be able to record directly on the
system for longer than 30 seconds I mean
the current way of getting your
screenshots off the switch and onto
something like your phone or computer
isn't terrible but PlayStation just has
an incredible solution where it's
actually all through the app now so when
you take a screenshot on Playstation you
can just load up the app and then it's
going to be right there you can save it
straight to your phone send it to your
computer whatever you want okay my
friend let's talk about a real life
struggle low battery anxiety is that
actually but fear not because the
Nintendo Fusion has got your back what's
with they're always talking about
getting your back got your back with a
better battery life you can go on gaming
marathons without interruptions explore
vast Virtual Worlds conquer challenging
quests and Unleash Your gaming prowess
without worrying about running out of
juice it's time to embrace the power of
Endless Gaming I said make it like
you're talking to a friend could you
imagine saying that to a friend it's
time to embrace the power in this gaming
and there you have it my gaming buddy 10
incredible features that are going to
take your Nintendo switch experience to
a whole new level can you feel the
excitement building up I know I can so
mark your calendars and get ready to
embark on a gaming Adventure like no
other alright my friend I want to hear
your thoughts which feature has you the
most hyped let me know in the com wait
they actually put that dude okay wait
I'm gonna try to read that in my normal
voice actually and see how it sounds
alright my friends I want to hear your
thoughts which feature has you the most
hyped let me know in the comments below
and don't forget to smash that subscribe
button for more awesome gaming content
until next time keep gaming keep smiling
and keep being awesome but for real
though
subscribe for more